Alright, guys!
"Unicorn Apocalypse" promises to be the biggest mobile game we've ever launched.
Yes!
We'd also like to announce a new smartphone policy.
To make things simple, you can now use any phone you want at work.
So you're finally gonna retire that thing?
That's cute.
You're not even working, you're watching basketball.
Actually, I'm closing deals with clients and watching the game.
Modern business, my friend.
This is business.
What, the jacket?
Did you have the partners' Note 2's ready?
Yep, here you go.
All set up.
Alright.
Are you sure these are secure enough?
These have on device AES 256-bit encryption plus support for VPN and NDM.
Now we need to decide, did the unicorns start the apocalypse or are they trying to prevent it?
What about you, are you gonna consolidate your phones?
Oh, no, I have a system.
This one is for work, this one is for home.
Great, but with the GS3...
Valerie, respect my system.
Right.
Yeah, I want it to look like a real unicorn.
The way they look in real life.
Okay, but real-life unicorns have rainbow blood.
Got the new game trailer?
Yeah.
Hold still.
Hey, what about glitter for the mane?
Really like how the horn's decayed but still lethal.
Oh, by the way guys, we're launching in four weeks.
What?
Four weeks people.
No one is gonna sleep this month.
I know a guy who can get us the Swedish energy drinks.
The ones from Sweden?
Oleg, it's Dave.
It's go time.
Oh boy.
The next big thing for business is here.
The Galaxy S3 and Note 2 with Safe Technology.